-Well, today is Friday.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff,
you know, I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course, I send out
thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was running
a bit behind.
You guys mind? Can I write out
some thank you notes right now?
Is that okay?
-Yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some
thank you note writing music,
please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
Looking into your soul, yeah.
-Wow!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Joe Biden getting
his annual physical.
[ Laughter ]
Although, it got weird
when he turned, coughed,
and more documents came out.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
You go, "Hey."
-What?!
What?!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, President's Day,
for letting us come together
as a nation
and celebrate what matters most
to us all --
cheap mattresses.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, hacky sacks,
for just being beanbag chairs
that entered the quantum realm.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, sour cream,
or, as I call you,
mean yogurt.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-That's what you call it?
You call it mean yogurt?
-I call sour cream --
-Mean yogurt.
-I call it mean yogurt.
-Wow.
-That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, microwaves,
for having the door open button,
the minute timer button,
and 40 other buttons
I never use.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Butter defrost?
Honey, need your butter
defrosted?
Ah, forget it.
[ Laughter ]
-Figure out the way --
-Sorry to wake you.
Sorry to wake you up, honey.
Should I defrost the butter?
-It's 3:00 in the morning!
[ Laughter ]
-It's 5:00 somewhere.
-[ Pop ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, showers,
for being a great place
to take a deep breath, relax,
and think about how much
I miss my phone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mumbling ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, scaffolding,
for answering the question
"What if a building had braces?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cymbals clash ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, pizza rollers,
for looking like my kitchen
knife hopped on a unicycle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my Thank You Notes.